bon vous savez pourquoi vous êtes là si
j'ai bien compris vous cherchez des
choristes pour duke sterling alors vous
allez faire quoi
l'info soit au super a déjà mais j'en ai
préféré d'autres si vous voulez non ça
ira
merci
[Musique]
oui tout va bien pas passer c'est juste
que tu me manques
essayez un laminaire non sûrement pas si
vous essayez pas ça risque pas de marché
veuille et un trio hachana jackson mon
nom ses critiques au nord je pense que
vous avez beaucoup de talent
[Musique]
tu m'étonnes ce type a écrit des
chansons pour tous les artistes de
contrer auquel tu pourrais penser y
compris duc sterling c'est comme ça vous
accueillez les gens et silverado je suis
pas prêt de partir je peux chanter je
veux écrire des chansons et je veux
qu'on écoute ce que j'aime
musique est super ces textes il pourrait
être plus personnel on pourrait faire
une chanson dont le sujet est la tête de
l'amour je veux dire qu'on sait que le
grand amour et quelque part mais on n'a
pas encore trouvé la bonne personne je
te pose en challenger s'agit vraiment
une très grand ma famille est
propriétaire du ranch où aura lieu le
festival solitude duke demande de
chanter au festival samedi soir avec
huit sur la grande scène est ce que vous
pensez de la proposition que duke a fait
tâche n ya de chanter avec lui c'est
génial la côte et sur scène tu es plus
la même personne enfin je voudrais pas
celle qu la personne n'a envie de voir
là vraiment
une chanson ça vient du coeur quel que
soit l'endroit où de produits
cette robe que par avis
dis pas que tu crois qu'il ya quelque
chose entre moi et duke je vois pas un
qui soit meilleure que l'autre d'entre
nous n'a pas besoin de dieu coupe lui
rendre
[Musique]